hey youtubers it's Charlie this is me
just catching up on agents of shield
episode 19 this week we finally got to
see the curry on the show or they came
back to the show because we've seen
cream before and legends of tomorrow
episode 14 so shield stuff first then
legends of tomorrow lotta big stuff
happening this week mostly spider-man
related fun fact if you guys didn't know
Marc Guggenheim who is the showrunner
for arrow does a lot of writing
producing for legends of tomorrow is
currently writing the agents of shield
comic book which features characters
from the TV show one of the latest
issues is a big spider-man crossover
spider-man crossing over with agents of
shield so just think about that on this
very spider-man heavy week it just to be
clear spider-man in the comics is a very
different character from the spider-man
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe movie
spider-man has only just become
spider-man in the last year comic book
spider-man is much older but I just
think it's hilarious someone who's so
embedded in the TV culture of DC Comics
is writing a Marvel comic book but
episode 19 of agents of shield is all
about hive trying to recreate the
original crea experiment that created
Inhumans in the first place that begat
that first generation that then passed
their DNA onto all the fish oil in
humans that we've been meeting this last
season Daisy in particular so when they
find out that they need Kree blood but
it gets trashed Daisy the big WTF
Daisy's like I have crib Ludd use my
blood that's the big WTF slam to buy so
they're gonna drain Daisy's blood or at
least they want you to think that
they're gonna drain her blood I don't
think they'll actually go through with
it because I'm pretty sure that Chloe
Bennett is coming back for season 4 but
just to explain the mechanics of that I
know that you know there may be some
questions about like how did they create
the first Inhumans the opening scene
with the Kree chasing down that
Aboriginal human was hive himself the
person that would become hive they
pumped him full of Kree blood and then
exposed him to the Terrigen mists he
became hive and got the powers that he
has today became the parasite that he is
today in the comics the reason that the
Kree created the Inhumans was to be this
weapon of mass destruction in their war
with the Skrulls there was this big
conflict called the kree-skrull war they
wanted to issue a final solution on the
Skrulls so they tried to create the
Inhumans but they were unsuccessful so
they just abandoned their experiments
but they had already create
a bunch of Inhumans so they became a
very isolated caste
based society that evolved separately
from the rest of humanity now the big
change from the comics is that we
haven't seen a tool and yet that's their
home but it's constantly hidden from
sight there have been a number of
different places that it's existed in
the comics sometimes it's on the Dark
Side of the Moon
sometimes it's directly over Manhattan
in the comics more recently there's a
place called new at to land there was
this big event where a Terrigen bombers
leased the TV show kind of did their
version of that with the fish oil pills
so right now hive is trying to create as
many Inhumans as possible because his
whole ability revolves around
controlling other Inhumans so the more
people on the planet that are Inhumans
the more people he can control you get
the idea
but because the Kree are such a big deal
during the guardians of the galaxy
movies I'm guessing that they said that
these creeks were not from the Kree
homeworld because they're not really
sure what the final look of the Kree are
gonna be in guardians of the galaxy - or
they just want to keep it as separate as
possible but the way they explained
these two Kree is that they were left in
stasis around the planet as a safety
measure so all in all it was a pretty
good episode agents of shield is getting
really really weird which I'm actually
excited about because Joss Whedon's
brother who's the showrunner all of his
strengths as a writer as a showrunner is
in the weird things that he chooses to
do with his characters so when it comes
to agents of shield the weirder the
better they did reveal on next week's
show that they're going to be doing
there big Civil War crossover the
official crossover and it will be very
much in the vein of the superhero
Registration Act via sokovia accords so
next week crossover but moving into
legends of tomorrow territory so I'll be
talking about legends of tomorrow
episode 14 so this week's episode is
being affectionately called
the everybody makes shockingly bad
decisions episode on the Waverider
Vandal Savage gets out their time drive
is damaged and then once we finally make
it to the vanishing point we find out
that Vandal Savage has been working with
the time masters if you're a big Doctor
Who fan this might seem familiar it's
kind of a version of the end of time
where the Time Lords decided that as a
measure of last resort they would
destroy they would end time itself so
the people you would typically think of
as heroes became the villains of that
story so the time masters of legends of
tomorrow very much in the vein of the
Time Lords of Doctor Who so this episode
felt like a complete mess it was meant
to be the episode where like everything
goes sideways like oh my god we're at
our lowest point the people that are
supposed to be helping us or really our
enemies now they're working with the
person that we're trying to kill WTF are
we gonna do now so I have very high
hopes for legends season 2 they've
already talked about two new characters
they're bringing on we got a teaser for
a big character that's gonna debut in
the finale he's being played by one of
the main characters for suits and he's
gonna be a season 2 character but we're
gonna meet him in the finale he's gonna
be a big comic book character they
didn't say who though I'm just I'm
hoping they take things in a
dramatically different direction so
because we only have two weeks left on
legends of tomorrow what's gonna happen
is is they'll price start announcing
more things about season two I'll be
sure to include those in my videos
because just like the flash finale last
year when like the big wormhole opened
above Central City there'll be some big
event in the legends of tomorrow finale
that'll give you an idea for where
things are headed in season two so let
me know in the comments what did you
guys think about shield this week
bringing the Kree back and what do you
think about legends of tomorrow how they
gonna kill Vandal Savage and which
characters do you think they're gonna
replace in season 2 just in general it
felt like this was a light week of TV
the flash is always pretty strong but
because of Captain America Civil War
just dominating everything it just felt
like a lot of the volume got turned down
on the TV shows but there are still some
really big things going on so be sure to
catch up if you're behind there's only a
couple weeks left from all these shows
what's gonna happen next is is there'll
be some Game of Thrones tomorrow so be
sure to subscribe to get that I'll do a
bonus video before I do my episode 3
video hopefully you guys have had a
chance to see Civil War it's amazing you
can click here for my easter egg video
they're about 50 Easter eggs that I
included in that and you can click here
for my review of the movie thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you